I'm here at the erad reservoir it's
around 30 miles away from where
Madeleine McCann disappeared in 2007 and
this is the place where police are
focusing their new search so if I move
out of the way you can see in the
background a specialist vehicle there on
the hills around us so we can see white
tents in the distance and police have
put in cordons so they can carry out
this on the request of the German
authorities and the reason that the
Germans want to focus on this area is
because their Prime Suspect Christian b
a convicted sex offender is meant to
have visited this place he was in Prior
dilouche at the time where Madeleine
McCann was visiting and he is the prime
suspect despite the fact that he denies
being involved so they are refocusing
their search we're told by local media
that they'll be using pickaxes and
specialist equipment to map the bottom
of this Reservoir and the land around to
see if they can find any human remains